el canal de suez sigue bloqueado por
cuarto día consecutivo y no parece que
vaya a desbloquearse pronto a pesar de
lo que opinan las autoridades egipcias
que creen que estará la vía libre a
finales de este fin de semana pero
expertos que están participando en esas
labores para quitar ese mastodonte
portacontenedores del canal de suez que
está bloqueando la vía desde el martes
creen que hay que mover al menos 20.000
metros cúbicos de arena para poder
conseguirlo y los más preocupados son
los economistas la economía global está
en suspenso porque el 12 por ciento del
comercio mundial pasa por el canal de
suez al menos el 7% del crudo y también
gas licuificado o el gas
petróleo refinado pasan por ahí muchas
empresas se están quedando sin
suplementos y creen que podría
producirse un incremento de los precios
en los próximos días debido a este
bloqueo que como les decimos no tiene
visos de solucionarse en los próximos
días se podría tardar semanas incluso
después de que se haya desbloqueado se
tardaría al menos dos días en retirar
todos los barcos que se van ya hasta 150
que llevan bloqueados desde el martes en
el canal de suez porque solamente una
media de 106 barcos pasan diariamente
por esa vía